Freddie Steinmark
pretty hard he's here every day after
his practice well I know he's
exceptionally dreamy you have to start
the car up at 7 7 is perfect it's
perfect
thanks Debbie you're really fast for a
big guy we will not lose this game
I'm singing buddy your size do as much
damage what you do out there matters for
me to get a scholarship hi sure you said
it weighs more than 145 pounds so junior
college well thank you anything you want
to see me coach I made iron mark watch a
season worth of film you got his
attention we got 200 players fighting
for a spot on a 100 man Rosco coach is
right about you mister
football doesn't build character it
eliminates the weak
I'm offering you a scholarship to attend
the University of Texas and play
football every other coaches thought I
was too smart play black the way you
attack you will not regret giving me the
chance sir give me my handbag no sorry
mark took a big hit looks like he might
be hurt you see you kind of hide your
limp on the field don't act like you're
not in pain I know you you're all right
son I think we have to have somebody
take a look at it there are a couple of
possibilities
I promise coach I will not let you down
I wanna play in the Copper Bowl baby my
boy that boys never back down against
nothing nobody and you won't now I'm
gonna need only whatever you're going
through I am going can't you hold up one
more game whatever it is you will meet
the challenge